oh this has been one of the greatest
professional experiences of my life i oh
really a lot to see far I wanted to
become a global scholar more than I have
wanted anything in my career to date and
I did they sort of crept up on me you
know when I first found out about the
program obviously I didn't really know
much about it and just the more I
learned about it the more excited I got
I think what attracted me the most to
see far as an applicant and now as a
global scholar has been that their
approach is big hard problems first and
foremost and this was an amazing amazing
in their teaching experience of meeting
not only people in my field but some of
the most brilliant young scholars from
disciplines all across all possible
fields in the possible nationalities so
I'm a social psychologist my group
doesn't have very many social
psychologists it has mostly people from
sociology and political science and
other kinds of disciplines I get to
really kind of hear the different ways
that they're thinking about very similar
problems and the different just like
things that I can learn from them is is
really great and the synergy between our
fields is really exciting let's just
bring the smartest people together and
and try and tackle those problems and
that's just been the most energizing the
experience for me as a researcher
[Music]